well you know it's going to be a great
hour when we have a doctor in the yeah
yes indeed that's for sure so excited
about that
thank you for joining us but we begin
this hour with a major development in
the fight against the coronavirus pfizer
is asking the fda to authorize its covet
booster for all americans 18 and older
the shots would even be available to
adults who received the moderna or j j
vaccines this is fizer's second attempt
to push boosters for most americans the
fda advisory panel rejected its first
request in august and limited the shots
to people 65 and older and those in
certain high-risk groups but pfizer says
it has new data showing the booster
offers almost complete protection from
severe covet join us right now like i
said u.s surgeon general dr vivek morthy
thank you for joining us yeah i'm glad
to be with you all today of course now
let's just jump right in pfizer says
this new data
it shows that the booster can provide
almost complete protection against the
covid virus um
do all adults need this
well it's a good question and that's
what the fda is going to have to look
into they'll have to examine the data
carefully understand whether giving a
boost to that additional group of people
that advisor is recommending is both
safe and effective but here's what we've
seen already from preliminary results
from uh from israel from their
experience they have seen a significant
increase in protection when they've
given boosters across the population but
the most important thing we've got to
remember right now is if you're eligible
for a booster please go out and get
boosted uh and if you haven't been
vaccinated at all it is imperative that
you get vaccinated because we still have
a lot of covet floating around and
winter is coming which means that
there's a chance uh that as more people
go indoors there's a risk for spread so
how soon can this specific pfizer
booster be available
well the fda will have to go through
their process they've been prioritizing
vaccines so i imagine potentially in the
order of weeks they will make a decision
around this but again it depends on what
they see when they look at that data
yeah pfizer tried to get this done back
in august september based on what was
happening in israel so hopefully it'll
be sooner rather than later can we talk
about the misinformation that's out
there about the vaccines you know we've
got the big story in the news about
aaron rodgers who seems to be using his
platform to spread misinformation how do
you deal with that what are your
thoughts about that
well gail i'm glad you brought it up
because health misinformation is one of
the greatest threats we have right now
in our coveted response and more broadly
for health it's one of the reasons why
in july of this year i issued a surgeon
general's advisory on the dangers of
health misinformation it's also why
yesterday i actually also followed up by
issuing a community toolkit that
families can actually use that community
leaders can use
to give themselves
training and tools to actually fight
misinformation in their own lives but
this is a fundamental problem because i
you know i think people have the right
to make their own decisions but i also
believe as a doctor that they have the
right to have accurate information
you know so they can make the best
decisions for themselves
that he's allergic to
to something that's in the pfizer and
the modern vaccine have you heard of
people being allergic to anything in
this talk about aaron rodgers yes aaron
rodgers yes so there is a very very
small number of people who may have an
allergy to one of the components of the
vaccine this is very rare though uh and
you know in those cases then they can
talk to their doctor and we can they can
look for an alternative vaccine
but again this is exceedingly rare one
of the the things i think to draw though
from this whole example that's been
talked about more recently is that who
you get your information from really
matters yes because somebody has
millions of followers you know in social
media because they happen to have a
well-known name does not mean that they
are a credible
authoritative source when it comes to
vaccine information and especially now
that we have a vaccine that's out for
kids 5-11 it's especially important that
parents know that there's misinformation
out there they talk to their doctor
their department of health their
children's hospital or the cdc to
actually get credible information about
the vaccine so doctor on the subject of
credible information accurate
information i'm a big believer in the
idea that the american people can handle
anything as long as they know what to
expect so on that point what should we
expect medium to long term from the
coronavirus is it now time can you tell
us and acknowledge that this is going to
be around it's never going to be
eradicated and at some point we're going
to have to just be living with it
well great question as we look to the
future i think what is likely to happen
is that there will be coronavirus around
for for some period of time but i do
think we can knock it down in terms of
its severity and second we can reduce
the number of cases so we can get to the
point where we live with it just like
any other respiratory virus that's where
the vaccines have been so helpful keep
in mind if you look at the delta wave we
experienced over the summer the vast
majority of people who had severe
infection were hospitalized or who died
were people who are unvaccinated and
that means again and tells us that these
vaccines are remarkably effective we
also have two new oral medications that
are on the horizon the fda has to review
their data but the initial trials show
that they were very effective for
reducing hospitalization and debt so
it'll be around for some good news to
come good news to come uh and you say
covert will be around for some period of
time i mean should people be prepared
for that period of time to be forever
well i think we can certainly learn to
live with it like think about the common
cold for example like we have learned to
live with the common cold and you know
we can take precautions to protect
ourselves but we know how to get through
it uh we can ultimately get covet i
think to a place where it's somewhere in
between the cold and the flu where yes
it's a virus that's circulating but it
doesn't disrupt our way of life doesn't
prevent us from seeing the people we
love doesn't prevent our kids from being
in school okay thanksgiving coming up
should unvaccinated people be
fraternizing over holiday dinner with
vaccinated people would you do that
asking for a friend asking for wearing
well look i think if you're gathering
indoors with vaccinated and unvaccinated
people together that is certainly a
higher risk situation especially if
you're a parent like me and you've got
unvaccinated kids at home because
they're not eligible yet or they haven't
gotten a vaccine yet then you want to be
especially cautious the other thing
though to remember is there are steps we
can take to reduce risk further wearing
masks indoors helps using testing
strategically can also help to reduce
the risk of people coming to a gathering
infected
all right and children can be vaccinated
over the age of five that that that's
coming you know you're coming i got to
love yeah you need to okay we've got a
long time to get vaccinated
that's a big big word especially for
kids like mine i've got a five-year-old
would be a problem if you said no i'm
not vaccinating mine so
that would be that would be a problem
that would be your problem it's so good
to see you in first of all you're a real
boy we only see you i don't know
so nice to see you thank you very much
so good to be with all of you more thank
you